[Music]
Disney Princesses are always huge topics
of discussion but have you ever wanted
to know more about the lovers keep on
watching to find out the ultimate
secrets that'll totally change the way
you see these characters don't forget to
hit that notification Val to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out why you should
almost always side I the Disney men
[Music]
Prince Charming let's start a bit light
prince charming is a narcissist we all
know this but just in case you don't
here are some reasons why prince
charming is actually considered
narcissistic narcissists will only think
of themselves and their own wishes they
love themselves just a little bit too
much and we know that prince charming
has a huge portrait of himself in his
own castle this wasn't that unusual back
in the day but still would you ever have
a large portrait of yourself in your own
house you'd have to have a lot of
self-confidence to be able to do that
sure he's extremely romantic but this
could all very well be a calculative
game speaking of Prince Charming there's
also a few dark facts you should know
about his original actor William Phips
William unfortunately passed away in
June 2018 at the age of 96 he was the
original portrayal of Prince Charming
but Disney only paid him $100 for two
hours of work nowadays voice actors like
Nancy Cartwright get four hundred
thousand dollars per episode Disney was
really able to get away with it back
then weren't they Williams prince
charming role launched the rest of his
career but we bet there are plenty of
Disney fans that have never even heard
of him before Prince Philip is anyone
particularly fond of Prince Philip sure
he's an important part of Aurora's life
but did you know that he has a much
darker side of course there's the
element of consent that comes with
Prince Philip's kiss but wait there's a
lot more to be angry about if you've
never read the French versions of
Sleeping Beauty you're in for a dark
roller coaster ride Prince Philip in
this story is actually a married King
the princess is still asleep and she
still gets a visit but unfortunately in
the story the king does a little bit
more than just kiss her there's a lot of
wrong things that happen in the original
book all we can say is that consents
becomes an even bigger problem in the
original book and we really can't
understand how Walt Disney was even able
to read the entire thing but what makes
the original story even worse is that
after her horrible ordeal the princess
becomes pregnant
the
visit her again when she has two kids
after she gets told the truth of how she
became pregnant she actually falls in
love with him yep you heard that right
falls in love breno Prince Philip's
character was not apt ation of the King
character from the original so yeah
we're not really on board with this one
Prince Eric if you think about it Prince
Eric is actually the absolute worst
so he gets shipwrecked and then he
doesn't even think about his fellow
crewmen he just lost that's a bit weird
right
he didn't even second-guess anything
about Ariel imagine getting shipwrecked
and then believing 100% the woman you
just met and not even questioning where
she came from
someone who just experienced something
as intense as Eric did would most likely
be in shock not in love and let's not
forget that when Ursula in person in his
Ariel he was ready to marry her without
even taking gassing her hair color
Prince Eric is definitely a weird topic
to talk about when it comes to his
affection for Ariel he seems to care
more about her outside beauty and her
voice rather than her personality
remember when he waited until she got
her voice back to marry her it really
does give you a feeling that there's
more to this story than just pure love
on to you Eric now can I open them all
right
[Music]
the Beast by now you should know that
most of the Disney characters are based
on the book version of the original
movies in the original story Belle's
actual name is beauty and she has
siblings
long story short Belle is the only one
that's likable because she's so
beautiful one day her father brings her
arose from the beasts castle and
obviously the beast gets really really
angry to stop his wrath beauty's father
needs to bring him one of his daughters
and Beauty agrees to go beast was
supposed to eat her but instead he keeps
her in his castle as a prisoner that
doesn't sound much like the movie
version does it this beast is clearly
living up to his name and there's
definitely no happy ending to the story
in several other versions of the story
the Beast is always seen as manipulative
in one of the stories beasts even has an
imaginary lover that's way more handsome
than the Beast
we love that Disney changed the story
and turned it into something more
meaningful but it just proves how the
original characters always come with
unexpectedly dark secrets Hercules
Hercules as a character is already
totally full of himself
the Disney managed to make him endearing
but Hercules his dark secret is that
he's not really endearing like really
his whole family is messed up and even
the rest of the Greek gods are known for
their bizarre behaviors but did you know
that Hercules has a dark past himself
sure he marries mogera but that's not
all that happens he actually ends the
life of his music tutor and as well as
all the kids he has with mogera oh and
mogera doesn't make it either sure he
feels a lot of remorse after it but
shouldn't he be shown the way he was
portrayed we appreciate that Disney
tries to see the best in everyone and
turn everything into a life lesson but
they definitely went a little soft on
Hercules and based on the original story
mogera definitely deserves more credit
and an official spot as a Disney
princess just look what she's been
through with this guy Naveen out of all
Disney Princesses Naveen aka the Frog
Prince doesn't really have a bad
personality sure he's a bit spoiled but
many other characters are too so we'll
give him a pass but as it turns out
there's more to his story
of course once again we're talking about
his original character from the original
princess and the frog tail who we're
telling you Disney is doing a really
good job at giving these characters
about her story Levine's original story
remains largely the same to the story
you see in the Disney movie but there's
one secret that makes his characters
slightly more interesting or frightening
depending on how much you like Naveen as
a frog the prince obviously did a lot of
things with other frogs if you know what
we mean but as it turns out his desire
to do that didn't really go away after
he turned into a prince
yep Naveen actually likes frogs like
really really likes frogs if you know
what we mean sure everyone has their
obsessions but this is maybe going just
a little bit too far don't you think
leashing okay let's step away from
original character stories and check out
some other secrets these people might
hold and leashing is the perfect
character to reveal some of his secrets
what are your thoughts on leashing
he's pretty powerful and deserves far
more credit than he gets because he was
brought up in a society where women
aren't equal to men I'll make a man out
of you
Tsonga rubbed some people the wrong way
he's also pretty socially awkward and
honestly we can definitely relate to
this part hands up if you're a socially
awkward person too but that's not Lee
Shang's biggest secret as it turns out
Disney has something darker they're
hiding if you've been following the
Mulan remake news you already know this
but if you haven't here's some news li
Shang won't be in the reboot yep you
heard that right
we've all heard theories that Li Shang
is bisexual so why would Disney even
want to cut out this iconic character it
makes absolutely no sense especially
since this revelation received a lot of
backlash
we hope Disney ends up changing their
minds because li Shang definitely
deserves to be included in the reboot
[Music]
will today be the day you're ready to
fly Quasimodo speaking of characters
that don't get enough recognition
how about Quasimodo sure he's not a real
Prince and Esmerelda isn't an official
princess either but let's be honest they
deserve to be on this list in the Disney
version of The Hunchback of Notre Dom
Quasimodo gets the happy ending he
deserves but in the original version
things get a bit more intense Quasimodo
in the movie actually has the exact same
name as the character in the original
story but they have a slightly different
fate in the book Frollo actually betrays
Esmerelda who ends up losing her life
for a crime she didn't commit Quasimodo
is so heartbroken he never leaves her
grave he eventually stops eating
completely and passes away from
starvation all while being next to his
true love almost two years later their
bodies are discovered lying together
after a single touch they crumble to
dust pretty intense for a character
that's actually one of the gentlest
characters in Disney write her kind of
glad Disney kept this one a secret and
changed the story into a happy ending
Peter Pan yep we're putting Peter Pan in
here too it's one of our favorite
stories but when you hear this theory
you'll probably change your mind about
Peter Pan's character according to his
original story there's something
absolutely wrong with Peter we might
know him as the boy who never wanted to
grow up but the original Lost Boys
Version know him as something entirely
different
Peter Pan actually hates adults but he
also doesn't really like the Lost Boys
according to the book Peter thens them
out when they seem to be growing he
doesn't want them to grow up which is
why the number of the boys on the island
constantly changes it's assumed that the
name the boys out means that Peter
actually ends their lives when they
become too old there's also a paragraph
on one of the rules of Neverland it says
that every time you breathe a grown-up
loses their life Peter always tries to
intentionally make quick short breaths
to speed up this process yup he really
doesn't like grown-ups sounds like he
has a bigger issues than we thought
we're gonna stick to the movie version
this is way too dark but not as dark as
our very last love John Smith let's be
honest do Disney fans lie
John Smith come let us know in the
comments sure he might be a handsome
adventurer but we all know he's not
exactly the ideal character well the
original version has an even darker
story
you see Pocahontas aka Metallica was a
real-life character and John Smith was
incredibly manipulative despite the fact
that the woman presumably saved his life
she actually hated him this Pocahontas
was kidnapped and used as propaganda but
the truth is John Smith wasn't even a
part of the Pocahontas love story no one
was in order to be released the original
Pocahontas had to marry John Rolfe John
Smith first mentions motto ACCA's saving
his life in one of his books a few years
later despite the fact that he never
mentioned this events before and any of
his older books no one knows for sure
whether Metallica really saved John
Smith or whether he actually played an
important part in her life
unfortunately the real-life Pocahontas
didn't have a happy ending as she passed
away very young the real John Smith's
claims of her saving his life are
constantly being questioned what do you
think was he lying
come let us know in the comments below
and that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]
[Music]